- We are back and I'm
here with my new pal,
Edgar Ramirez, give it up!
(audience applauds)
All right, we are standing
at our Lectern of Integrity.
♪ Lectern of Integrity ♪
(Kelly laughs)
Oh my God!
We don't pay Jessi enough.
In honor of Edgar's new movie,
are you pushing it Edgar?
- I'm pushing it so far.
- He's getting amped up for the game.
- In honor of Edgar's new
movie, "Jungle Cruise,"
it's time to play a new
game called Jungle Clues.
♪ Jungle Clues ♪
Here's how it works.
Edgar and I will take
turns giving each other
clues about animals found in the jungle.
We cannot use words, only
motions and animal sounds,
which should be funny.
If we can correctly guess
eight animals in two rounds,
the audience wins a fabulous prize.
We're trying not to let
you down just so you know.
- For you.
We're doing this
together for you.
- Yes, this is for you.
This is for you.
So I'm guessing first and
you're giving clues, okay?
- I'm giving clues, yeah.
- Okay, are you ready?
Because, hey, we can pass if
you don't know what it is,
you just say pass.
- Okay, cool.
- Okay.
Yeah, you're fidgeting.
It's too bad you don't have
any paper twiddle it down.
- Yeah.
- Alright, cool.
And,
go!
(Edgar imitates frog sounds)
- A frog.
- Yup.
(bell dings)
(Edgar imitates monkey sounds)
- Toucan, a bird.
- Yeah, no, no.
- Oh, a monkey.
(bell dings)
Oh, I didn't hear you.
- Okay.
- Oh God.
(Edgar roaring)
- A lion.
A hippo.
(bell dings)
- Yeah!
- Oh!
Yes!
A giraffe.
(bell dings)
Whoo!
- Are they in the jungle?
Okay.
- A dragon or those Komodo dragon?
Lizard?
(horn honking)
- Pass, pass, pass.
- Pass, pass.
Oh, wait, are we supposed to switch?
Oh, we have to switch.
- Okay, okay, okay.
I hope I'm as good as you.
You did good.
I'm sorry I failed you on the last one.
Okay, that means we need four
more for the audience to win.
Ready, and go.
(Kelly hissing)
- A snake.
- Yes
(bell dings)
- Okay.
(Kelly imitates hyena sound)
- A hyena?
- Yes!
(bell dings)
Sorry it was horrible.
- Sloth?
- Yes!
(bell dings)
Okay.
Can you see me?
(Kelly caws)
I don't know what they sound like.
- A horse?
- You know, look at the leg.
- The leg?
Ah, like flamingo?
- Yes!
(bell dings)
(buzzer buzzes)
Yeah!
(horn honking)
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
This is the part where we hug, but.
- I don't know...
We can't.
- I know.
- Here we go.
I love that I don't know
what a Flamingo sounds like.
(Kelly caws)
- But you did the leg.
- I was trying to do a bird.
- Like, you see me?
- I was so unsure.
We did it.
That means everyone in our
house seats wins as well.
Your welcome!
- You won.
(audience cheers)
- So with Hydro Jug, get
all the water you need
in the jungle, y'all.
The gym or anywhere else you go.
It holds 73 ounces of water
and the leopard sleeve
slips right over the bottle
to keep it cold.
You're welcome.
Sleeves come in all sorts
of colors and patterns
along with a shoulder strap and pockets.
You're all getting a
$200 Hydro Jug gift card.
(Kelly imitates horn honking)
All right, thank you so much for playing.
Everybody catch "Jungle Cruise."
It releases July 30th.
You're gonna love it.